Christy you mentioned chaotic dating
kind of at the opening you want to tell
us some of the chaotic stories that
you're dealing
with um yes so I would say so I've been
single for about a year now and the last
person that I dated um he was a lot
younger than me and I I was a lot
younger uh eight years okay I mean and
so when you're talking about I'm in my
mid-30s he's in his 20s to me that feels
like we were we were literally speaking
a different language um and I don't know
if it's a generational Gap that type of
thing so I found that to be extremely
chaotic and I always got like the guys
that are in their 20s talking to me and
like harassing me until I'd be like okay
I'll go out on a date with you you know
what I mean so that was that was what I
would consider very chaotic because I
didn't you know really understand some
of the like things that he was doing
they have different acronyms like
they're just from a different generation
so I would call that chaos and I dated a
couple younger guys and I actually am
not ever doing that again so why did you
do it so I mean we had a great
connection at first he was super
good-looking guy um and you know things
like from a physical perspective were
all the way there but as time went on I
realized that the values and the morals
didn't align and it wasn't you know it
wasn't going to go anywhere long term so
I decided like no more it's not it's not
going to happen anymore I was when that
interesting because there's always a gal
that's like yeah you know I was dating
this guy he was a lot younger than me
blah blah blah and inherently women are
generally attracted to guys 7 to 10
years older right um guys's attraction
comes with wealth success influence
connection social network it's more than
you know just does he look nice in a
bathing suit sort of thing right um
whereas you know you get the common
Trope like you know Leonardo DiCaprio
he's always got a girlfriend and as soon
as she hits 25 he breaks up with her and
he trades her for another one right and
it's like I don't know if women try to
replicate that they're like oh that
looks interesting Leonardo doesn't so
let me give it a try sort of thing and I
get that there's a lot of like guys that
are older or as they get older they
don't function properly sexually because
they kind of like let themselves go they
get fat their cardiovascular system
sucks they don't work out there's a
whole bunch of reasons for it but it
it's always interesting me you know like
you think you're going to try it and
it'll work out but it never seems to
work
out has it ever worked out for anybody
you know dating a dude that's a lot
younger like 8 10 15 years no
okay um what are the stories you got
with the chaotic dating you said you had
a whole
bunch I will say that I also um I dated
somebody that was even younger than that
and I
moved oh so he was 20 he was 23 and I
was 33 and you moved in I moved him in
and I felt like I literally moved my
nephew in and I was taking care of him
and he literally had me in his phone as
stepmom
so okay yeah it was it you don't feel
sexy when it gets to that point like you
don't feel you know it it just wasn't
and I was totally so turned off by that
I'm like all right so I need to like you
know it was kind of like fun trying
something new but it didn't work to your
point it doesn't so your dad was around
at that time what did he say about 23y
old living in your house he did not
approve and you didn't listen to him I I
didn't listen to him but that voice in
my head like after he gave his opinion
was always like you know what it's it's
not going to work I knew it wasn't going
to work but it was kind of like a safe
bet because I wasn't going to get super
close with him where I knew it didn't
have that longevity Factor so I was like
yeah well and then I told him to go home
to Mommy eventually so I gota ask you
this question because I mean women are
generally interested in a man's future
like what can he do to preside protect
provide for me all this sort of thing
are you concerned at all about your past
decisions dating younger guys when it
comes to dealing with a new man in your
life I am because it was like a very
weird role strain as I was like the
bread winner for certain situations and
that is not something that I want for my
future I want it to be in a different
way I want it to feel more like they're
an equal somebody that I respect as an
equal competency wise intelligence um
career and and like being established
overall in life I think I think that in
my future that's the lesson that I've
learned is like that's not going to work
we're in two different places in life so
we're in different we're not only in
different chapters we're in different
books on different bookshelves so what
do you do for living Christie I'm a
business operations project manager
that's a lot of words for something I
don't know what that means what do you
do it's it's a fancy term for um
operation operational project management
for um I work for a global advertising
company so I do various different
projects with internal stakeholders and
external ones so as far as a guy that's
your equal so what would he need to earn
as far as um you know an annual salary
to be with you um it would have to be a
six-figure income yeah um I I think that
would I mean but in today's economy I
mean I think that's that's a pretty
normal thing for at least I mean I would
think it is for somebody mid to late 30s
I would say that that's a good um goal
to have to like have that income earning
potential at by that age are you running
into a lot of guys that meet that
criteria you
know what I would consider a high value
man I feel like there's very slim
pickings what is a high value
man high value man is what they would
call toxic masculinity what the what the
masses would call that I don't believe
that's a thing going on what you know
Beth had suggested earlier um it's it's
being a man in every sense of the word
it's it's being comp competent it's
being a go-getter that means that
there's going to be a lot of failures
along the way but overall you're
successful you can lead me and I've
never really been with a man that could
lead um that I trusted to lead and I
have no problem submitting to a man
worth submitting to but I just feel like
I haven't found that yet so you will
submit to a man that's worth submitting
to absolutely because women today are
very difficult to lead even even you
know conventional anti-woke conservative
feminist women can be very difficult to
lead still a lot of guys myself included
will find difficulty leading a woman
that even you know says that they want
to enter your frame and be useful and
all that sort of stuff it's always fine
and you know the other part of that too
is though as soon as a guy starts
hearing stories about oh well you know
Chrissy dated a guy that was eight years
younger he moved a guy in that was 10
years younger into her house you know he
was in her phone a stepmom sort of thing
you know I think high value guys are
going to start looking at you like um
okay cool I'm going to go over here now
sort of thing um so you kind of limit
yourself to you know the dating scope of
guys that you're looking for as far as a
high value man I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out